en tout cas cinquante ans après la
parution du deuxième sexe de simone de
beauvoir la ligue du droit des femmes
organisé un concours d'arts plastiques
et d'écriture dans tous les lycées de
france
avec ce thème on ne naît pas femme on le
devient au cours d'une soirée très
festive six jeunes lauréats ont été
récompensés le reportage geneviève moll
et jean-françois hoffman si je vis mieux
avant
donc ne vous entend toutes ces femmes
veuves quelque chose à simone de
beauvoir dans les années 50 lorsqu'elles
ont vu le deuxième sexe elles ont pris
conscience qu'elles étaient des
individus à part entière des êtres
certes différent des hommes mais avec
des droits comme eux quand je dis que ça
va me donner un avenir
ça m'a donné ça m'a permis
d'entreprendre avec les moyens que je
sentais que j'avais c'était dur dosé
entre prendre envers et contre tout ma
mère
après avoir passé l'agrégation chimie en
1949 a décidé de devenir universitaires
en chine où elle a lu le deuxième sexe
et alors qu'on l'a dissuadé de devenir
professeur de chimie
elle a trouvé la force et l'énergie dans
la lecture du deuxième sexe pour devenir
une universitaire dont je suis une
enfant du deuxième sexe dont ce livre a
changé toute ma vie aujourd'hui simone
de beauvoir est enseignée en première et
en terminale et les jeunes s'insurge
toujours contre les violences faites aux
femmes comme l'expriment ce collage
d'une des lauréates
mais le probable du féminisme le pur et
dur l'heure semble dépassée
il apparaît que les hommes
d'une manière générale
un progrès de la paix
il ya pas de guerre entre femmes et
hommes c'est complètement aberrant
à force toutes les filles sont plus
évolués que les garçons parce que les
allemands braqués sur elle
elles sont tellement recherche de
liberté et tout et tout que en fait
adorer aller de pair en fin de compte
pas
on va passer de l'ère de l'homme qui
écrase la femme à la femme qui trace la
stupide
ces jeunes filles sont livrés conscience
tolérante mais combative et simone de
beauvoir
il est pour beaucoup voilà c'est l'heure
de se quitter joue